what's the deal with airplane my great
grandfather didn't have legs so you got
to expect that
you know i'm gonna have lean calves
we're just still sprouting them out you
know we're still working on the family
lineage
it'll be another three generations
before we got some [__] you know
beefy low pieces in our jeans my place
was a pet shop and had a pet shop in the
front
and low-key in the back they was doing
you know sexual offers bro
but and my buddies they were real
perverts you know yeah and i'm in there
looking at these [__] parakeets and
all kind of
cool hedgehogs birds mostly dude it's
the [__] jungle bro
hedgehogs the [__] out of here dude look
it's montana
um they had real beautiful animals in
there and everybody else is trying to
come in the back and i'm trying to catch
one of these [__] beautiful parrot
let's help dude you don't think you you
now now just be that honest do you think
you bought a cheap parrot and they got
your dick slapped in the back
i do remember what happened they had
some we went in the back and
and i got super nervous and then i left
and i didn't i didn't
i'd and then uh what did your buddy say
go down did they [__] a toucan or
something
i don't know how strange you got but the
funny thing to me was the parrots knew a
lot of
english and they would mimic a lot of
sexual things they'd heard you know like
oh
get that bonnie you know and it was so
crazy
about the boss
[Laughter]
white guy cheap white guy cheap i can't
cheat
i think that's what they said after the
white guys left why i got cheap yeah i
don't like to i didn't like to party
i just like to put myself in a crazy
situation [__] that yeah me too
you know i was that's what i was
thinking about the whole time you're
saying that i go yeah
i don't miss the drugs i miss the six
o'clock on a diner or
waking up and some girl gives you an
audi to drive home
yeah you're like what the [__] just
happened last night yeah dude i was in
louisville one time i came out of a show
they had a big group in a limousine they
invited me to go to after party with
them right
i was like i'm only coming if my boy can
come in like who's your boy
and i'm like le cedric they had a
brother nearby right wearing this louis
vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and i
didn't even talk to this dude right i
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come
so i [__] walk over him looking right
in the eyes and i was like
what's up man i'm theo he's like and uh
i was like all right dude i told these
people you're my friend you ever been in
a limousine he's like nah
i was like all right come get him with
us just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there
hot chicks dudes people [__] little
cedric kept saying we're friends that's
what he kept saying
out loud right not the best actor bro
what did we get to this house party it's
a nice cool [__] party bro
i'm downstairs i'm in the kitchen
somebody's making us a drink i'm talking
to somebody
[__] six minutes later right here
[__]
somebody scream i hear a window break
right
somebody comes running down they said
some dude just stole like four
purses out of the coat room upstairs
and [__] jumped out a window
that would have been me doug and that
was [__] less cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something i remember
she got pissed she was a tough girl
we're on this bus right yeah and the big
rule this young kid's rule was who
wasn't sleeping was
no [__] on this bus right and the first
day i was like guys don't use the
restroom
but after about 40 hours and no sleep
he's like i dare somebody to [__] on
this [__]
right so
literally we're on like day three uh on
one of these tours and we're somewhere
and it's [__] eleven o'clock at night
right yeah and i tell this dude
bro miss margaret who is the older
karaoke
one margaret yeah just [__] in the [__]
right
and this dude has not slept bro he's
doing it all
no does whatever driving a [__] half
million dollar bus right with
seven human beings living in it and
whatever girl
who was banged and is still asleep in
one of these uh you know pods
who's gonna wake up in white plains new
york and have two options one take a
greyhound home
or two uh be our merch girl
be our merch girl which really was
nothing because there was no merch
be our merch girl so oh
so next you know this lady comes out of
the bathroom she probably just urinated
or put on some extra lipstick right
but i'm like dude miss margaret just
took a [__] in there right
so this dude [__] pulls the bus over
on the interstate has
lost his mind jumps out of his seat
jumps on miss margaret right shut the
[__] up
starts literally choking this lady out
on the floor bro i'm not joking miss
margaret's partner mr dan right who is
the male
karaoke guy yeah literally cannot bend
over to help because he had a bad back
right he had best posture i've ever seen
yeah also to get a rod in his back or
maybe two rods
yeah but uh could not bend down to help
so he was just like
yelling i'm like should i get somebody
to help should i
get somebody else bro this is hella
[__] exciting right
it's a midnight and there's a [__]
the skinniest guy
ever who hasn't slept in two and a half
days choking on an adult woman
who's selling hangover beverages and
doing karaoke
scooping up [__] imagine if your grandma
just [__] all over your yarn
just go out go on the lawn just she
shits in the yard
shits on the lawn like oh grandma's out
there [__] i go clean up her [__]
yeah i love her but god i hate cleaning
her [__]
yeah i would hate cleaning up probably
human [__] for some reason but i
remember than dog [__]
well when i was a kid they had a boy in
our neighborhood named mario right
and he uh and he was dude he ended up
dying actually he did some pills and
drove into an embankment
but he when i was young he would [__] in
his yard make me bury it
and that's how that's how i was allowed
to be friends with him
how did he make you bury it he just
asked me to do it and i was afraid not
to do it i think he said
yo dude you're not going to believe this
but i took a [__] and um it's out my
yard i can't even bury it because i'll
throw up
can you do me a favor and go bury it
yeah he was he dude he was dark man
he had a he had a real dark vision and
he would uh
he would i mean he probably honestly
dude
he probably [__] 200 300 times and i
buried it
i swear to god i swear to god i swear to
god dude and he um
how'd you not run out of places to make
new holes do you think you ever dug up
old [__] to put in new [__]
oh yeah i wouldn't be surprised man we
basically had like the only setup i had
not even have a strong system the only
setup i had was like a
one of those plastic uh you know beach
oh
like a beach setup dude i'm talking i
was seven so wait a minute this
seven-year-old was doing this how old
was he he was eight or nine
oh he's tricking you but yeah and older
he was older
and two years when you're seven is a
long stretch you know when you're 32
yeah
32 to 34 that don't mean [__] whatever
dude seven and nine that's a big stretch
yeah you go [__] at your house buddy
that's what i tell people now
[Laughter]
so for two what he would what was the do
you remember the first
there's no way you really remember i
remember what he said
i remember what he said but i remember
how did it happen how did it happen when
you find yourself
with a plastic shovel and another
person's [__] going damn
how did it come to this well it came to
it
because he i know my brother probably
wasn't around and i wanted somebody to
play with and he was older so i was
hanging out
and he was deviant man how so he just
had a little bit of like um
like he was kind of slithering you know
what i'm talking about from uh
he knew how to manipulate you yeah he
was obviously you buried his [__] 200
plus times
like there wasn't he had the same color
in the outside of his eye on the inside
of his eye you know what i'm talking
about
demon yeah like a lightning diablo yeah
like a el diablo but also who was in
elementary school
oh interesting um but he um so when you
first found yourself
do you remember the the feeling that you
first found when you were
digging a hole for a dude [__] like just
thinking what
am i how long can i do this what if he
keeps asking how do i stop this
how did you wind up stopping that's
maybe a better question you know what i
don't remember how it kind of you know
pant you know how it turned off yeah
petered off
i don't remember how it kind of tapered
off his parents ever like hey do you
ever [__] in the house
how come we don't have any missing
toilet paper well dude you know that's
what i think it was i think he was lazy
where you know he was
i'm serious and he sat outside behind
his uh slide they had a slide in his
yard because he had you know a little
bit of money
and he shot outside behind the slide
this is a great word too by the way and
it was silty kind of
soil and sand and i remember going over
then i still remember
the same night bro i was asleep in this
guy's room and he had a bunch of pets
stacked up along the walls because he
loved all kinds of pets
and where's five of us sharing a bed
right and um
and all night bro i can't sleep right
because i'm scared of all these animals
i'm scared of all these animals bro and
i can't sleep right and so
uh i'm just thankful this one this dog
keeps barking man
i'm so high that there's this dog i'm
just thankful that this dog
outside the window keeps barking i'm
like because i'm awake i can't sleep
right all the other four kids in his bed
are asleep
and you can just hear these pets moving
in their cages and he had a big ceiling
fan in the middle of the room that was
spinning right so it's like
whirling up all these pets right and
even though we can sleep is keeping them
awake because you got to think a ceiling
fan for a pet that's got to be like you
know
a [__] tornado going off constantly
right we don't think about that you know
so i'm [__] laying in the bed
thankfully this dog barks every now and
then it keeps me company right even
though it's outside and then you hear
boom boom boom
boom boom my buddy's dad walked out
there killed the dog right
outside the [__] window boom
went back to sleep dude same dude that
hours earlier have been smelling a young
man's hand man
same man and that's what blew my mind
about the world like how could at one
moment a guy be
so gentle yeah and then seven hours
later be blowing a freaking
animal's head open because it was
barking you
know you have an animal in the woods bro
it's gonna bark you know how much woods
is out there you know he probably hears
everything
they say they can hear everything
imagine hearing six times something
you'd [__] be angry you know your
neighbor you know four houses over
i don't know man i'm high bro first you
talk about incest [__]
talking about killing dogs they got to
bring me down sorry i'll bring you down
that down [__] hot dog i'm sorry
sisley told me his girlfriend don't do
laundry oh
damn
if you're really in love with it you
should [__] leave a load over there
when you go back two days later see if
it's cleaned
her mom would have just loved no but the
thing is she still lives with her mom
her mom would do it oh wow
her mom has offered [__] yeah bring it
over there fold me on these put starch
on them
is her mom married to a brother or not
have you ever
[__] makes you feel like you have a
checkbook you know it makes you [__]
feel good
bro bring up another picture of jeff van
vondren please from intervention
dude you should get jeff van roger on
here ask him about kratom well just to
talk about supplements and how people
can get addicted to those i bet he would
have a ton of stories yeah he would be
fun
dude that got me amazing
well he just yeah i know he did that he
had that gig with monopoly for about 20
years and then
he was helping people recover from dope
he's got i'm sure
uh work at the front of a train for
about eight months and then he'll die
and that's probably gonna be unfortunate
because all the people in the
intervention all the therapists are
former addicts
yeah they act better than everyone too
no they don't yeah they act like oh
yeah they are better they're only better
than people who are addicted that's it
it's one step no they throw that [__] in
their face
i've been there look at me i did it oh
look at look at my life all right bro
you got a [__] suit on you're obviously
here i don't want that for myself
they're not bad people they're helping
people change yeah they're talking about
it so you know what i'm saying like
that's what drives me nuts about
intervention
they're real cocky about it there's a
guy shooting a heroine into his nose
okay
they gotta be cocky about it dude
you gotta be comfortable when you're
dealing with those people
oh it did look like here oh damn at
least he's in shape
oh now i don't like how they throw that
[__] in all the addicts face though you
know what i'm saying they're not like
you got to be willing to cut them off
kick them out of the house
no money mom are you ready to do that
like [__]
no that's my son you [__] and then they
all go to a radisson
and have a big free-for-all in one of
the games why they always got a rating
i don't know what that like the ramada
is oh people are nice
too yeah i know yeah it's usually like
you're right duressen ramada in
uh sometimes motel six depending on the
guy oh
dude motel 666 bro people get gunned
down at those all the time right
ramada has the murder rate at ramada is
unbelievable
ramada it's either murders or you get
your dick size there's no in between
dude the third floor of ramada always
closed for murder bro
there was always a murder it's always
there's no more that's where you go
dude they had a mint on my pillow one
time i thought it was a [__]
crack no oh damn great see that's a gift
dude i like seeing rare things man they
used to have i remember
activities you think you do where you
come a lot like the kind of people that
like
power lifters probably shoot giant loads
right i think you would think they do
but for their size and stuff they're not
doing that much
who do you think shoots the biggest
loads oh i think a guy that's in space
i think a guy that's on a cliff like a
cliff
climber yeah but is that the biggest
loads
i mean that guy's shooting some [__]
just because he has the balls to climb
up like that he's busting some real
spackle
maybe that's what it is like he's got
balls like those guys shoot bigger loads
yeah like bmx jumpers they jump three
times in the end and land on the bike
yeah maybe they have the biggest loads
um
also guys who like fake put a sign on
their car when they don't pay a meter
like meters broken they just put that on
their car
if i can still park there those dudes
bust
some loads bro i think there's other
things too
like pickpockets oh people that wear
turtlenecks do not come
very much or far no what is it about
wanting to keep your neck warm it's not
very manly
it's just a [__]
[Laughter]
it's such some french thing too
and i don't care about the french dude
dude this [__] is getting
gay bro today sorry i gotta fight
it's just very dick oriented today i
wouldn't say it's gay well it's that
time of year it's spring
people are spring it's the middle of the
winter yeah it's freezing cold out it's
just
january whatever you guys don't know you
guys aren't open-minded
that's what i think it doesn't get more
winter than january
not even a groundhog's day yet why did i
just say it's august okay
oh yeah dude no [__] me and freaking
shout out billy conforto dude he's on
the topic today but me and him used to
pull off the interstate and shoot
steroids into each other's butts
oh dude i could [__] for the first
time in my life i could keep my hopes up
man i was strong
where did you get the steroids from uh
we got them from this guy
sean were you competing in any sport at
the time or you just want to get swole
just looking nice in math you know that
was it just trying to look nice in math
class and i even remember my math
teacher one time dude and she never gave
me any attention she always looked at
all the handsome boys in our class
and i remember one day she finally said
wow theo uh that shirt looks
nice on you and i knew what she was
[__] saying yeah we're doing sean
steroids
i knew what she was saying dude i knew
her husband wasn't enough so yeah
yeah her husband when she got home today
he wasn't gonna be enough yeah dude i
like seeing rare things man they used to
have i remember
they had somebody called in our podcast
and they said uh they'd never seen a
black little person before oh like a
black [__]
yeah and they had one in our town dude
and he had these dreads right
this dude named uh no dante right no
dante
yeah and he had these dreads bro and
they were he they were so long he would
[__] trip over him when he was
running bro [__]
but he was a [__] g dude yeah and he
would play basketball but he would like
he would kind of cheat a little bit
because it was almost like sometimes
you'd almost catch him playing soccer
but he was so fast you could barely see
it
like you would kick you with his feet
but since he was short you'd let it
slide yeah you let it slide not where i
come from but you're really going no
no no no you can't have that yeah man
people i think he was like a
town mascot people loved him man i don't
know i love how you take calls on your
show
you just take how do you filter out dude
well i assume
there's not too many people calling like
talking [__] like you're not getting
trolls and stuff
no we had a guy a lot of people will
have difference of opinion we get some
stuff talking stuff
different is fine but it's knowing
they're going to call me like you're the
worst comic ever you [__] suck you
hack and then hang up or anything
i don't know i haven't i haven't got
much of that you're going to get a lot
of people crying jerking off we've got a
couple of dudes [__]
[__] and no leaving voicemails yeah i
have to do a catheter
do the voicemails yeah people leave
voicemails and then we play them back
oh that's super smart yeah because some
of these [__] moocs you can't have
them just running
no i figured you got a producer who's
controlling it like all right caller
seven
here we go we got jamie and dallas jamie
what do you got for theo
hi theo i'm here and i'm worried about
my boyfriend he's been doing a kind of
ton of coke and grew a mullet out and
he's starting to act a lot like you
and are we gonna make it you know is
that like yeah you're gonna make it at
least
two years in a row baby you got at least
two years in you
i guess it's something like that man um
yeah it's just people just
it's a lot of dudes that are just
addicted to jerking off mostly and just
struggling
so struggling with jerking off all the
time bro that stuff's killing people i
think
don't pet the playboy that's what i'm
gonna make a shirt that says that on the
back
don't pet the playboy dude well the
scary part is i start to think is this
the best i'mma look you know
yeah i'm going downhill myself yeah i
got another year before people are like
oh [__]
shots falling off like a [__]
when calvin's been falling apart man
bless his heart dude i saw him the other
day
and man i don't know if they're not i
mean i thought he was a look like he
just went to an early movie he looked
like a senior
you know and it was just weird i
remember so i became friends with this
french black kid named devin deku right
in our town
and uh i remember i go over this house
and we'd go in his house and it was cool
to just be like
in a black kid's house and just kind of
see what their life was like and real
intimate and like um
and i remember bathing with his sisters
in this tub in their front yard
and uh what was i can't remember what
this one
i think this dude might have been a
pedophile but he kept yelling something
at us
uh oh i can't remember what it was but
anyway devin and i went fishing one time
sometimes we go get like
lunch meat or whatever and go fish right
yeah well one time
these bull these white kids are walking
across this
literally these standby mirrors are
going over this brit this train track
over this water where we're fishing down
by the river
and they start throwing rocks at us and
calling us the n word yeah and i'm
trying to yell to them
i'm not the n-word guys
guys are you color blind just one of
them
i'll back off and devin my buddy evan is
dying that i'm trying to like because
i'm also i think i'm mildly doing it to
entertain him you know
yeah so it was but at the same time
dodging rocks from these racist kids
who obviously have poor eyesight you
know um
so i don't know i mean just just things
like that just growing up in a place
that was unique
so that's what i started to incorporate
keeping that mentality dude i remember
when
before they even had child pornography
when children were just not you know
doing that
and they had um somebody one time when i
was in college sent me a picture
of two old men and they were naked in a
room i remember getting this email oh
lemon party
and they probably seen the same image
and they had a kid like sitting on a bed
oh no i haven't seen that image
right and i in my mind i'd never thought
about
old people when children and sex you
know or anything wild like that so
i remember seeing him be like oh this is
[__] hilarious
but i remember seeing him be like what a
crazy idea like you know everybody
is naked you know and so like life is
naked this is just
you know it's almost like an art like
this is how people you know it's like
this is when they're old and this is
when they're young and these guys are
you know watching tv or whatever you
know i thought
so i sent it to everybody i knew i was
like guys
this is so silly and dude i remember
like two years later running into an
ex-girlfriend
and she goes what have you been up to
with your life right
she goes yeah well nobody will forget
that time that you sent that picture of
two old men
and a naked kid to everybody
and i was like that's what that was i'm
like that's what that was if you look at
it like a creepy [__]
excommunicated by everyone you know but
i just thought it was
like i thought it was like seeing a
couple rabbits in a yard you know when
you see two rabbits on a goat's back
like in a photo
sure yeah like i thought it was like
that oh let's just
mix the world you know i didn't think of
it as sex oh my god
did you get any responses oh no that
girl once when that girl told me that
then i started to feel
i mean i think that probably made me
feel bad about myself because then i
thought
i don't remember i don't even have that
account anymore i don't even know who's
on that email list
who had seen that right that is still
looking for you
she also said the kid she goes was that
you in the photo because the kid
looked like me a little bit and that's
why i think somebody had originally sent
it to me like hey man is this you
and i was like no it's not me dude i
don't know two old people that would be
naked in a room with me
you know and just taking photos but i
wasn't thinking like oh these guys are
being dirty
you know it's sad that you can't even be
safe you can't be even clean anymore
sometimes if you want to
of heart without it going to like a
dirty place you look at a tribe
you see now those photos those people
standing around a fire all the time
everybody's [__] naked yeah but
that's okay no i agree it's
you know you throw two you know through
two seniors and a you know and a
seven-year-old and a motel six and
suddenly that yeah
email that to everyone you know yeah
that's not cool that's not kumbaya bro
you know that ain't zaire the dutch are
so aerodynamic
they move good no you ever seen a dutch
they're really aerodynamic they're
they're what what are you doing with
your hands lean face lean headed
no they're not four inches cheek to
cheek they're big people man dude
dude how big they are the dog hoe
they're very tall but they're
very aerodynamic very aerodynamic the
downhill people they call them dude
you know where you're looking for an
occupation but you're if you're not
doing that you're probably up to some
dark art
you know
it's like elvis for the holidays
you want some [__] memphis email list
oh look i'm walking at i'm about
7 11 the other day you know just minding
my business kind of just kind of seeing
what was happening in the area
in 7-eleven huh no outside of it oh word
dude nothing good happens
none of the fun stuff i don't feel like
ever happens inside of the seven
never unless you're by the slurpee
machine that gets a little tricky
yeah and you might catch a blow job you
know somebody doesn't have a slurping
machine works yes
so i'm out there i end up in the uh
i'm outside in the parking lot and
there's a man a ginger
tall ginger and he's walking by with his
child he's a child
another same ginger or no no the child
looked a little darker i thought
you know and i've mixed a lot of things
in my life i don't know if i ever go
ginger and urban yeah you know yeah yeah
that's i mean that's
it's not there's nothing wrong with it
you know it's rare though oh you're
gonna be able to dunk
you know but it's gonna i mean you get a
blake griffin is what you get yeah yeah
you get a blake griffin but you also
could get a
you know um your potato too though yeah
yeah you can get a potato
yeah you could get an eggplant yeah you
could get that redheaded eggplant yeah
you don't know
nobody likes yeah dude you might get
you might get a stuffed animal you know
you never know
so that's that risk you know but what
happened was so
i'm walking across i walk i'm outside of
the 7-eleven and this dude yells out red
cake
and bro the crazy part was there's two
other homeless dudes outside the
7-eleven
so they did they think that he was
referring to this yes
and did the one of them looked
and put his hand in here yeah yeah right
king baby
you know i eat them right
so i didn't know who this guy was just
for a second i don't know who he's
talking to
you know it took you a while to register
it oh and then he drags his kid over the
kid is wearing a brazilian jiu jitsu
outfit right
and i don't know if it's called a ghee
yeah yeah the kid was wearing a gia
and the uh and they walk him over and
the kid is
screaming crying like does not he's
scared of the rat king
so see i mean he's probably scared of me
he's scared of me
oh he's getting the other rat kings in
training boy
he's scared of this i mean he's scared
that his dad is dragging through a
7-eleven parking lot
you know while he's wearing basically a
japanese man's dress is what that thing
is and so anyway the dude hits me up in
the parking lot he's like alright gang
and he's like i love you man this kid is
crying his kid starts using whatever jiu
jitsu moves there are on him like on his
leg right
just totally and that doesn't give a
[__] oh the dad doesn't give a [__] dude
you can just
trying to get a glimpse of the real oh
gee
you can tell he's going to beat the sun
at the house yeah as soon as you get out
yeah
you embarrass me in front of the right
king like that little [__]
so that was wild man you were just
chilling out front the 7-eleven though
yeah i was looking for trouble or you're
just kind of chilling no i just like to
see who's in the neighborhood man we
have a lot like at our 7-eleven they got
a lot of it's a lot of pimps come by
with escorts you got a red box out there
like if a plane crashed i already know
i'm playing the head dude i need a
vietnamese guy
why um because that's easy it's a
starter move if you attack somebody
bigger
if you eat somebody bigger in front of
other people it's going to alarm people
but you you got to eat a small person so
stature is important
i think if you gum down a viet people
aren't going to be that upset at you
vietnam these people are going to be
super upset what are you talking about
somebody's dad
yeah they're sacrificed they're more
understanding of things dude
is this a character you're playing no
but if you eat a black dude you eat a
black lady and her family's there
they're gonna be pissed
so you think a vietnamese person will
let you slide i think that they'd be
much more forgiving over a couple of day
period
i think uh their relatives you don't
think so honestly
one thing no i don't think so i
definitely think they'd be super pissed
at you
especially modernized ones but what is
interesting is like vietnam is one of
the few places where
um americans can go back to vietnam and
they don't seem to
hold any grudge at all exhibit a
[Laughter]
exhibit a man honestly well asian people
in general are just
much more forgiving and understanding it
seems like i feel like
i think i mean i don't have much i think
i think that's a giant generalization
it probably is you know i mean i did a
fast for like four days and then i was
at the best buy
and um and i remember this vietnamese
guy was trying to help me out and i
couldn't even hear him i was so hungry
and i couldn't you did a fast for four
days oh dude yeah
what are you trying to prove i don't
know man i was probably just dealing
with some stuff and i was just trying to
find a different way to handle it you
know
right um and then i remember this
vietnamese guy
and i remember thinking if everybody
turned the other way for a second i
could eat this young fella you know
ben his name was ben actually over there
in westwood
um but and i never thought it's so
ridiculous
well i mean but here's the thing i'd
never thought that before so you only
thought you got to the verge of
cannibalism after just four days
yeah damn how much weight did you lose i
probably lost about
four pounds but pounds i needed you know
but i got clear man i could
and i could hear swear to god y'all
could hear somebody fold a piece of
bread from 80 feet away bro
i was so hungry dude i could hear a
[__] skittle hit the cement
across the street i really focus on
learning more spanish so i can uh i want
to do a special
uh just spanish yeah like in nicaragua
or something my dad's from nicaragua
so i want to do a special in nicaragua
yeah your dad is not nicaraguan
uh we might have to edit that out dude
because
that time closer okay go one more time
bro i want to see
how racist this ends up nicaraguan whoa
bro
a couple of guys just shut up at the
door dude how do you say
you can't even speak on kratom can you
jesus christ
uh you say it nicaragua bro you are not
nickel roglin
yes bro my father's from blue fields
nicaragua i'm polish nicaraguan [__]
lied to you no you're not
broke you're a hawaiian and for death
right
beth get over here bad dude another time
this dude my buddy billy conforto rest
in peace bro he died he drove into an
uh embankment but he um he used to do
pills and everything and we were bus
boys together we were co-bus boys
even though he was about 35 or 40 you
know he looked like don flamenco you
know that is from mike tyson's punch-out
the little italian guy and he's like no
no
he looked like that guy but without the
roses and about an extra 20 pounds and
he was also homosexual
but he uh he gave me some pills you know
gave me some somas one night or
something i think try to maybe take
advantage of me i don't remember that's
a good thing about pills is
you know what i'm saying if you did get
molested you don't really have to
remember it
but i remember uh this girl this hot
chick that i knew
was at this bar we ended up at and i was
like i need a ride home
i mean i was i sat in my passenger seat
she drove us home
while she's driving i vomited all over
right
and the only thing i remember is we made
plans to go to church the next morning
so in the morning i come out of my house
have no clue
how i got home open the car door and
there's vomit everywhere except like in
the shape of this woman right on the
on the front car seat and i went over to
church and she was there and she looked
at me like i was the devil himself man
you barked on this poor girl yeah she's
a sweet girl too man
and she has children now because i've
seen on instagram she have some children
i'll do all [__] with is uh dog the
bounty hunter oh yeah you and him look
like brothers
oh dude hey can you is that your dad
his dog dude bro what the [__] are you
talking about dude
bro don't [__] touch me after you're
a dick dude
[__] dick no way bro
your daddy
he dyes his hair dude and he he has
asthma too and he uses the n-word
doesn't he see it so we have a couple
things in common but that's
it bro bro you guys look good
[Laughter]
yeah it's like her stomach just [__]
hooked to her chest and then
uh then got a divorce but it looks
like your tits are taking shits probably
look at that
oh my god dude it looks like 50 year old
dude's ass on her chest
that's insane don't reach over here you
[__] bloated
italian you look like an italian dude
that drowned and then just still
lived oh puerto ricans you were talking
that
they used to say uh that's when you guys
oh i was talking about the first mexican
kid we had in our town right
so we had class with the hamsters right
going back to that right the
the man mr mr blackwell's class we had
the hamsters they let you keep the
hamsters after superman got killed no no
that was it i just mean it was that same
time right everybody would get a
different pet
we used to play this game where you
would like somebody would lay down and
you would put a snake on their back
or a fake snake on their back right and
you would play guess if i have a snake
on my back or not
right and people would literally bet uh
if they did or what they were gonna
guess and then sometimes we put this
game where you because they had this one
rabbit in there that was always falling
asleep is like almost
hey you know like uh whatever rabbit
narcolepsy kind of is you know he just
drifts off you know because it's a
rabbit they're not doing much you know
and you would set a rabbit on a pile of
money and you try to pull the dollars
out from under them
and uh and without waking them up that
was like the biggest
thing we used to do in class before
class but the problem but
not the problem but the thing that
happened was this mexican kid moved in
named nick right
and the first thing he ever said in
class the main was uh in science they
also taught you sex
ed right so like the first day this kid
nick was in there i was doing the sex ed
part
and he stands up and he goes uh
he goes what does pop that cherry mean
that's what he said
he asked about your teacher like it's
serious he's gonna be like we'll just
pop that cherry me
and then he uh he ended up banging some
girl like in sixth grade right
and uh and she broke up with him broke
his heart and he
he started like rap music and he wore
this t-shirt that said
nick the rapper that he wrote on it with
a marker right but he only put one p
in it and it said nick the raper on it
the [__] shirt that he wore
and they [__] expelled him they
expelled him
that's racism uh i guess he was mexican
but see mexican didn't play a part and
he was a bad spell or any [__]
i was asking stupid questions what does
that cherry mean
where's where i'm from dude i remember
my mom actually won a perm one time on
the radio when i was young
and some other [__] from across town
said it was hers
[__] like [__] they know who won i
know you know what i'm stuck
doug [__] it i know who won the firms i
don't trust people from louisiana
well i mean it's a hit or miss state you
know it has a lot of um
that dark magic mullets are not frowned
upon
at all it's actually the ghost yeah yeah
it is it
do you think you see yourself ever going
to church again yeah i would think so i
think church
is kind of evolving over our time and
stuff like that and
um would you go to justin bieber's
preacher carl lentz
you know who he is yeah whoa he texted
me actually whoa
he's trying to groom you trying to pull
you in is he a dark heart
hello do you wear your shorts huh oh i
saw you guys making fun of his roots
yeah that was a little wild huh so you
know him i've never met him
no you just text each other back and
forth yeah we communicate sometimes
yeah that's that root
but i've never met him but i would go to
each other
yeah he's trying to meet you and you're
like not tonight bro
you think he's homoerotic no oh no i
mean
that's a weird way of putting it i think
you're homoerotic what
bro you're way gayer than me bro
you always every time i'm here you talk
about
jerking off the magical hat we almost
wore
what about is that the problem it's like
you came in here with like gay
expectations no i got
nothing dude murphy's that [__]
because you've heard of papa john's
right
murphy yeah papa murphy's i don't know
if they have them in l.a been denver
it's a [__] chain
you buy frozen pizza you get your pizza
and i don't want to get at home
dude i want a real pizza place i want an
angry ginger manager
yeah i want a couple of i want a black
guy who doesn't give a [__] cooking my
pizza yeah i want pizza hut
okay no no no no what dude i want real
bro
yeah once i send me a
we'll bring two pizzas king it or sting
it yeah bro
what pizza are dominoes yeah dude
dominoes is basically you dominos
domino's is like somebody took a can
full of pizza flavoring and just sprayed
it in a box and brought it to your house
[__] pizza pizza hut is real pizza it
has pizza in the title pizza
domino's a [__] board game yeah like
it's selling you pizza
hut that's like how obvious is that what
should we call it well we
we're in a hut we make pizza yeah this
is [__]
stupid at least they have pizza in the
title i don't need that to know they
make a delicious product
what do you mean domino's obviously not
dude it's delicious
oh my god bro most people are dying how
many skateboards did that haircut come
with have you seen his [__] haircut
unbelievable yeah both of my seven and
five-year-old nephews dude
let me ask you with that lesbian haircut
do you get a discount on subaru outbacks
does that work are they just enforced
green or
how does that work dude this haircut's
phenomenal i think
no i'm not mad at it bro you got virtue
this guy's at worse bro
oh you're gonna die soon you have aids
i'm like i don't have aging like age
isn't a big deal dude you shouldn't
really be worried about it
you know i wasn't worried about don't
touch me again that scared me i woke up
in my own bed i had no claw
got there i'd wet the bed i mean i went
to the bed i was about 30 anyway
did you two not told her until i was
like a teenager
oh that's nothing bro and uh
and and that was a pretty crazy night
one second you went the bets you were
13.
probably i don't know be probably around
there i would guess yeah
it might have been a little bit like
maybe not 13 but close maybe 10
at least well 10 ain't far from 13 if
you're talking at least
[Laughter]
no but yeah i know i had a huge issue
with it it was terrible dude i said i
used to have those buzzer underwear bro
they put these
underwear on you when the urine would
hit them a buzzer would go off oh my god
i'm not joking look him up online this
ain't no joke bro
so i went to my grandparents my mother
didn't tell him that i had these right
i'm really hoping these are a real thing
and not just like a torture device your
parents but honey not at all
they made by themselves this doctor gave
them to us dude this dude was a bunch
of google this dude was a bonafide
doctor so we went there i got the
electric pants on dude
you know wait wait would you like google
i'm getting my rest probably uh you know
buzzer underwear for urinators
google buzzer underwear for urinators um
and uh
so then but they didn't tell my
grandfather right
so he [__] had a small house bro a
little bitty house
so my [__] crotch is just but like he
he wakes up middle of the night dude
you're on fire i'm not on fire but i'm
buzzing hard bro
because i'd had apple juice man and i
pissed big on apple juice dude
i [__] spray out on the aj so i'm in
there just
buzzing dude i didn't know god and he
came in he still got him
yeah give me a penalty that's what i
want
give me a pen he didn't know what was
going on oh my god
that's what he comes in he's scared
how loud is this in a little bitty house
you could uh you could hear from down i
just want to wake my wife up in the
middle of that like twice a week
i would just do two drops and you and it
goes off
and uh and so my grandfather's in there
right
and he's all scared and [__] and uh oh
this would have been terrible when i was
a kid
and he's pushing me with a broomstick
dude he thought i was dead dude he
didn't know what had happened and we
thought i was possessed or dead
he's pushing me with a broomstick to
wake me up and he was worried because he
had one of those heart makers
and uh he was worried he would get
electrocuted he thought something was
happening he thought the house had
short-circuited
or the phone company had [__] up
that's what he thought the phone company
to uh swingers party on accident in
denver's below we're we're partnering up
top
went below and said do not enter me my
friend's like he's like bumping down
there
so we went down there and we realized
there's a swingers party because they
had a sign on it
it had like rules but it was like i'd
say the ratios
ten to one dudes they got to girls yeah
not good
not good enough like the the seven girls
that were there and the
70 dudes i just felt bad for him yeah
i'm like girl let's get out of here
they were you could tell their their
morale was not hot
yeah their self-esteem was not booming
well that's why you got to have like a
robert e lee type of guy in there you
got to have a straight up william
wallace running up and down the
you know the blind invade them yeah to
motivate these chicks at us
yeah you gotta keep the morale high
because if reality hits you go
what the [__] am i doing you don't need
that
yeah you need to be passing out dsw you
need that tony robbins dick game going
on
you know you need that dude dropping
knowledge of those girls
women join me you can do this
yeah man women have put up with a lot
dude just kind of like a regular guy
maybe about 6-1 but getting shorter by
the hour almost because old age
oh really yeah old age takes a lot of
density out of your bones
that's why if you're really old i feel
like you should almost
i don't want to say like bathing milk
but you want to you want to get the
suppositories or something you want to
yeah yeah just hide calcium in your ass
or whatever you got to do to bone up
you know to get marrow heavy i'm serious
yeah how old are you
i'm in my 40s are you really yeah look
older than that actually dude a little
bit
no
you're gonna have fun though man dude
which is bottle of pills you got down
here
this is that [__] school shooter
pills dude this is what this is bro have
you seen this
but you can't have this man ah yeah
that's what's making this guys people
like that do that in las vegas and
everything man you can't have yeah maybe
i don't know man
cradle should take these in china and
see what happens you should take these
in china
i'm not taking those back to china
they're probably you know what they're
probably from china
yeah that's what i'm saying this one buy
some out there and just get [__]
weird my
buy a geisha like cape or some [__] oh
i'll buy some outfits and stuff but i'm
not gonna get it we're them
out there oh yeah one with the culture
man that's a good point actually get
fully chinese
yeah go full you know don't get racist
about it don't wear like a raiden hat or
some [__] but we're like
[Laughter]
let's not stop talking about that for a
second because just in case this is the
last time people ever hear from me i
want to make sure they know what
happened no i've actually chilled out on
[Music]
them
you